did you hear them say let the bodies
pile high in their thousands or it's
only killing 80 year olds
there's been a few different versions of
this of these stories knocking around
um there was a version of the of
of it in the sunday times which
uh was not accurate but the version
that the bbc reported was accurate
and you heard that i heard that in the
prime minister's study
okay and next question that was not then
that was not in september though
that was immediately after he finally
made the decision to do
the lockdown on the 31st of october
okay next question you showed us a
whiteboard
picture and one of the phrases on it
that i think has
um caused some concern is who do we not
save
what was the answer to that um
well that that was asking the obvious
question at that point
you know at that point it was too late
to stop disaster on the 13th of march
was
was my view and the people who i thought
you know
got figured this out best view
so the the comment on that comment on
there was essentially like we're already
partly over the cliff
like who is not going to be saved in
this situation
have we figured that out who's going to
be who's most vulnerable etc etc